what do you think is the role of Love In
The Human Condition at the highest
philosophical level let me first ask
what's
um
like romantic love romantic love let's
say romantic love I have one or two
areas of apparent expertise in my life
romantic love
definitely not one of them so like lions
versus Bears I'm good animal combat I'm
good pretty good at and then different
grappling Arts Judo [ __ ] Jiu Jitsu
season uh wrestling uh for MMA so
fighting and so on romantic love you
don't see them as similar it's a kind of
fight
it's a kind of dance by the way
there's a sense in which I'm kind of
glad I'm not an expert on that imagine
what it would be
to be an expert on romantic love you
would take the one thing in life that's
actually interesting and make it boring
because you've once you've develop an
expertise about something you can start
to predict how things are going to
unfold you get answers before events
even occur you see you can read into the
future of everything
um I think there are certain parts of
human life where you want to be a
beginner at all times and you don't want
to gain expertise so excellence and
systematizing something in order to
achieve Excellence might destroy the
Very Yes yes and I think that the the
magic of romantic love is the fact that
we're all beginners at it and the minute
you try to gain expertise in it
what does that even mean like what would
it mean that it would be good I didn't
think it would I think you'd be better
off just
having fun with it and plowing through
and making dumb mistakes and looking
like a fool and
um uh and then whatever
success whatever that means comes in a
kind of light-hearted frivolous kind of
way and
um and that I think is
over the course of a lifetime far more
desirable than having you know expertise
and and Affairs of love so I don't think
it's even a good thing to study too much
and I think if you did you would
actually take something good out of your
life
yeah there's there's communities that
people call pickup artists that try to
optimize
this particular aspect which is of
dating of of guys picking up girls and
turning that into a system and seeing
what's the most successful I think that
would be
I mean maybe the first few months would
be good and then after that I think it
would be a disaster
um uh I mean
given that
humans are feel easy to study from a
from the standpoint of psychology I'm
sure it's not that difficult to gain
expertise and
things like picking people up the same
way advertisers can pick up your
attention to sell a product you can do
the same thing presumably with romance
and sex but
I don't know I feel like
if if you became very good at it
you would end up being very disappointed
by the results and
um so as I said I think there's there's
some things in life where it's better to
be a beginner and this is one of those
yeah enjoy the chaos the push and pull
be a beginner and make that a lifelong
journey that's really inspiring to hear
you say that and there's a deep truth to
that that also justifies the fact that I
suck at it
um I think it also justifies and it
would sell very well that John Donner
should write a book on dating and that
would be chapter one Embrace being a
beginner chapter two will be bear versus
lion
pivot quickly to violence